en el último vídeo hablamos de la idea
de que si yo entierro un hueso en algún
lugar y si mitos o carbono-14 y descubro
que tiene la mitad del carbono 14 que yo
esperaría encontrar en una planta o en
un animal vivo y dije y tal vez ya ha
pasado una vida media y para el carbono
14 una vida media es de aproximadamente
cinco mil setecientos treinta años
así que dije tal vez han pasado cinco
mil setecientos treinta años desde que
este hueso fue parte de un animal vivo o
tiene esa edad aproximadamente
ahora cuando hice eso hice una
suposición bastante grande y algunos de
ustedes han tocado este punto en los
comentarios en youtube en el último
vídeo esta estimación que hice se basa
en la suposición de que la cantidad de
carbono 14 en la atmósfera ha sido casi
constante desde que este hueso vivía a
la actualidad la pregunta es es
constante
la cantidad de carbono 14 en la
atmósfera y en el agua y en plantas y
animales vivos y si no es constante como
calibra su medición para que pueda
realmente descifrar cuánto del
carbono-14 encontrado corresponde a las
plantas y animales vivos en ese tiempo y
la manera en la que puedes hacer esta
calibración porque resulta que ésta no
es perfectamente constante la forma en
la que puedes hacer esta calibración de
hecho hay dos maneras y tengo aquí fotos
de ambas una es observar los anillos de
crecimiento
en árboles
y me dijeron que esto funciona hasta los
10.000
años
hasta los 10.000 años de edad no sé de
ningunos árboles de 10.000 años de edad
y no creo que alguien lo sepa pero tal
vez hay algunos restos de árboles viejos
y puedes buscar sus anillos creo que la
mayoría de nosotros estamos
familiarizados con esta idea de que cada
año que un árbol crece forma otra capa
de corteza así que puedes ver hacia
atrás en el tiempo observando esa capa
de corteza para así detectar la vida
media del carbono 14 y luego descifrar
cuánto carbono 14 estaba en la atmósfera
en este periodo de tiempo así que es un
tipo de registro de la atmósfera de
hasta hace 10.000 años si incluso
quieres ir más atrás puedes observar los
depósitos en las cuevas y la palabra
elegante para estos depósitos en las
cuevas
espeleotemas
leo temas
podrías estar familiarizado con las
estalagmitas son espeleotemas que
parecen estar saliendo del piso de la
cueva o las estalactitas que son
espeleotemas viniendo de la parte
superior de la cueva pero la razón por
la cual estas son útiles es porque están
formadas de carbonato de calcio tienen
carbono en ellas y poco a poco por más
de decenas de miles de años el agua en
los depósitos de la cueva deposita ese
carbonato de calcio así que es un
registro de la fracción de carbono 14 en
algunos de esos años y puedes alcanzar
resoluciones tan pequeñas como 10 años y
entonces esto nos dará muy buenas
estimaciones por arriba de decenas de
miles de años hasta 50 mil años y
francamente el carbono 14 no es ni
siquiera útil pasando los 50.000 o
60.000 años esto nos da una
bueno
registro
de carbono 14 en la atmósfera suponiendo
que es lo suficiente uniforme en toda la
atmósfera
y todas las evidencias sugieren eso y
esa uniformidad en toda la atmósfera
también se va al suministro de agua y al
interior de plantas y animales vivos
ahora el otro punto y profundizar en
este un poco realmente se presenta
porque estamos expulsando tanto
combustible fósil en este momento
estamos cambiando la cantidad o la
proporción de carbono 14 mucho mucho más
rápido que lo que ha pasado en otros
periodos de tiempo solo para responder
la pregunta realmente en los últimos 50
años aproximadamente donde el uso del
combustible fósil ha explotado hemos
estado cambiando la proporción de
carbono 14 relativa a los otros isótopos
de carbono pero bueno de todas maneras
espero eso haya eliminado algunas de tus
preocupaciones sobre la suposición que
hice en el último vídeo donde dije que
el carbono 14 era relativamente
constante
hay formas de ver hacia atrás años
específicos y descifrar la cantidad
relativa de carbono 14 es una manera
bastante buena de estimar qué tan viejo
son los seres vivos especialmente
objetos que tienen menos de 50.000 años
de edad